the tension that i'm feeling now
and the sensing that dan is doing
is the tension that we need to
and my keep or awareness
wasn't like this talking to the camera
and now all of a sudden i'm gonna
fight try and try to try and find that
again is it there
is it not there i'm now going inside
myself and i'm defeating
the whole purpose so what we've done was
i made sure
that the tension was there while we were
talking
because my awareness has to be there all
the time
the same as our breathing reservoirs
and that's what i want you to do i want
you to realize that your sensitivity
we've gone back now to this
balance being the same
so the whole thing is sensitivity
this is what we need to try and take out
this is when we go inside ourself rather
than go inside ourselves
sensing well i'm going to balance this
up
right that's how tight i want it
i went off a little bit okay
see i can't lie to his subconscious
or even if we don't speak he now knows
when it goes
and however subtle i try and do it
he'll know all them feelings
and the day we can touch each other
we'll know how sensitive we must try
them to become
all right shia nagi we're just trying to
anchor integrity
into ikea